the tarmac of djibouti's international
airport is far from home but for the
people on this airplane it's Refuge from
the street battles and airstrikes in
Sudan
the U.S Canada Japan and several
European countries have been evacuating
their citizens by air from Sudan to here
many of them have been waiting for days
for a chance to make it to the pickup
points without being caught in the
fighting it starts every morning
and it
will continue till
six o'clock at the morning they start we
can't sleep we don't sleep at all yeah
this is a fight in the two group is
fighting for their benefit not for the
people
Djibouti is a hub for these air
evacuation operations because it hosts
the militaries of several major Powers
including the US and France
after arriving here people have had to
wait several days for onward travel to
their home countries
Japan which also has a military presence
here says all its citizens who wanted to
leave Sudan have been evacuated it's
mostly military aircraft like
have been flying to Sudan and Landing
whenever or wherever they can and then
the people they're rescuing say they've
often had to make treacherous Journeys
to reach the aircraft to be able to be
brought to safety here in Djibouti
it's only the government workers and
some citizens of wealthier Nations that
have been brought out in this way
tens of thousands of people have been
trying to leave Sudan by land others
don't have anywhere else to go
many of the people arriving here have
had to make painful decisions families
have been split
Osama and his family are among several
who are now stuck here because they
don't have the required papers or the
money for onward travel
he says his British passport has expired
and all of his money was stolen by armed
men on the way to the pickup Airfield I
had to go through
36 checkpoints
from
opposite
factions from the rsf we had to go
through and then through the Army we had
to go through as well even for those who
can continue their Journeys their
worries aren't over
everyone here has loved ones left behind
no one knows if they'll be safe
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera Djibouti
foreign